tonight we're taking game night up a  notch oh boy someone in this room is  going to be taken and it's gonna be up  to you to find them it's a murder  mystery party whoever finds the victim  wins the grand prize you're not gonna  know what's real and what's fake wait a  sec you can't just come in here and  break the door guys make sure you get a  piece of this cheese it's just okay  Roger dad you drive safe  I've always enjoyed the camaraderie of  good friends competing in games of  chance and skill to revalue it seems  like Ryan you go first I'm scared  [Music]  it's not a joke people are in real  danger  [Music]  Oh take a little bath it's so much worse  stop wait me I have kids at home now  with an ass like yet you don't oh thank  you oh no he died  his instructions on how to remove the  bullets didn't have rubbing alcohol it's  like I eat this lovely sharp good idea  way to pivot and then a squeaky toy  for the pain  [Music]  you